member
ah there you are it's time to get up and
go bargain hunting Plus that shiny new
Xbox one s caught your eye well
Microsoft has launched a new promotion
that you may want to consider I'm Lucy
and welcome to your cheap as chips
gamespot news updates from now through
until October first you can get a free
game of your choosing when you buy a new
console at a number of retailers
including Amazon target gamestop and
Microsoft's own store this offer is good
on xbox one s bundles that already come
with a free game such as the halo Madden
and fifa bundles so if you plan it right
you can get your mitts on multiple
freebies xbox one s bundles start at
three hundred dollars some notes about
this deal it doesn't work on pre-order
games or second and consoles get all the
specifics on the xbox wire at the link
below the new xbox one s debuted in
August the system is forty percent
smaller than the original model and
features an interior power supply it
also features HDR support for some games
and comes with a new Xbox one controller
that has bluetooth support and textured
grips so which free games are you gonna
pick up let me know in the comments
below I'll come find me on Twitter I met
Lucy James games but more on Xbox one
make sure you keep it gamespot